my best friend's family like basically
adopted me when I was like 13 and took
me and like now every holiday I go see
that but like my family I was born into
they were just very crazy all their
money was very elite not I it's so hard
I I can't say a lot of things for legal
reasons there's like a whole with your
parents which is nuts well so how long
did you live with your parents
technically until I was like 15 but like
by 14 I was staying with my friends for
like months at a time it was just a very
volatile environment my parents were
like in their 50s in my opinion weren't
very good people like I did everything
on my own for as long as I can remember
it like just even my meals and my money
and getting to school and doing anything
that's one of the main reasons I dropped
out of school nothing was a functioning
routine anytime I really needed to fall
on a parental figure for anything it was
always my best friend's family there's
so much trauma and so many things that I
can't wait to talk about one day
Jeanette McCurdy wrote that book that
was like I'm glad my mom died I didn't
like that it 100 holy